for three days we've only imagined what
it must have been like for the 39 people
trapped inside this container now we
have the final heartbreaking messages
from a 26 year old Vietnamese woman who
told her family she was heading to
England via China according to a
Vietnamese human rights group farm trami
texted her mother I'm sorry mum
my journey abroad doesn't work mum I
love you so much I'm dying because I
can't breathe
her family say she'd paid 30,000 pounds
to smugglers the Vietnamese Embassy in
London say they passed her details to
Essex police the task of identifying the
victims and establishing cause of death
continues more bodies have been
transported from Tilbury Docks to a
hospital for postmortem I can confirm we
have offices working around the clock
and we have now arrested a full person a
48 year old man from Northern Ireland
was arrested at Stansted Airport earlier
today on suspicion of conspiracy to
traffic people an on suspicion of
manslaughter it follows the arrest of a
38 year old man and a 38 year old woman
from Warrington during warrants executed
in Cheshire overnight I'd also like to
make an appeal to anyone living
illegally in this country who could help
our investigation please come forward
and speak to us without fear I can
assure you that your information will be
received in the strictest confidence and
no criminal action will be taken against
you the investigation is focused on the
two parts of the vehicle found in Essex
on Wednesday the tractor unit at the
front and the container unit where the
bodies were found one of those arrested
is the cab driver the vehicle was
originally registered with a Bulgarian
plate
the containers owners global trailer
rentals limited at least at the unit on
the 15th of October but it's not yet
clear to whom when it departed as a
bruger and arrived at Purfleet it would
have had one of these manifest forms
where it would have declared the driver
who delivered it who it was received by
and what the contents were supposed to
be a huge number of lorries come and go
through the port of Purfleet so many
that it would be impossible to search
all of them but people who live locally
say they've seen hundreds of migrants
too many to be stowaways and you'll get
stop to knows where the missus stationed
in broken English or haven't got any
money or Walter Manning for Walter
my labor they asked not a poor guy poor
guy must be so desperate knocked on the
neighbor's door and asked for shoes no
shoes
they're just treated like commodities
that's what they armed these traffickers
she claims the authorities didn't seem
interested when local people reported
what was going on the company which runs
the port has declined interviews while
the police investigation goes on but
this week's tragedy will lead to greater
scrutiny of this back door to Britain in
woods Sky News SS